we need to know where he is look I know
he's in prison
except he's not in prison Hello friends
it's Naz Perez and Welcome to our new
show more like this where we bring you
more shows to check out like the ones
you already love today we're going to be
uncovering the mystery of five bingeable
shows based on the little series that
could Luther Idris Elba stars in this
show and also now a movie as a character
a detective who is both brilliant and
yet emotionally impulsive Luther debuted
in 2010 and it is run for 20 episodes
total across Five Seasons all of which
are fresh with three that are certified
Fresh Plus Elba has earned Emmy
nominations for all but one of them I
mean that dude is impressive and now
movie continuation has arrived in 2023
on Netflix called Luther the Fallen sun
with Idris elbow reprising his role and
being joined by folks like Annie circus
and Cynthia arivo yes please
I need to stop this man I'm still a
copper
not anymore
refused to stand down Tactical Unit will
shoot you dead so once you've finished
that film that's based on this series
this list should no doubt fill up your
show
two days starting with our brand new
pick Poker Face this murder mystery
series was created by Ryan Johnson and
it stars Natasha Leon in it she plays a
Vegas casino worker who goes on the run
and winds up solving crimes from town to
town with her unique ability to tell
when someone's lying I can do the same
thing but only if the question is about
McFlurries anyway the recurring
Supporting Cast includes Benjamin Bratt
and Ron Perlman while a whole boatload
of guest stars fill in the holes for
each episode like Adrian Brody Chloe 70
Ellen Barkin and many more you can
mention first and only season so far in
about 11 hours on peacock which is way
better than listening to the song Poker
Face by Lady Gaga for 11 hours I could
tell she was lying what is it it's a
woman's intuition no it's not like a
tampon commercial okay it's a real thing
next up is our certified Fresh Pick mind
Hunter this Netflix series is run for
two very certified fresh seasons and is
based on the 1995 True Crime book called
Mind Hunter inside the FBI's Elite
serial crime unit it stars Jonathan
Groff Holt mcalleny and anatorev as part
of the FBI's Behavioral Science unit as
it was first forming in the late 1970s
when criminal profiling was actually
becoming a thing and much of the show
features agents interviewing famous
serial killers in an attempt to solve
other cases so among the executive
producers for mine hunter are Charlize
Theron and David Fincher the latter of
which directed most of the episodes and
basically served a showrunner
unfortunately for me Fincher has put to
rest rumors of a third season coming to
Netflix but never say never I guess in
the meantime 19 hours is what you'll
need to binge the first two seasons and
I say do it who's the one you want more
than anything Manson I'll get you Manson
This is one hundred thousand dollars and
it's all yours if you help us identify
the persons behind the murders of our
children in Atlanta our throwback pick
this week is In the Heat of the Night
this mystery crime drama takes us back
to the late 80s and early 90s with a
series that was actually Loosely based
on the 1967 film and 1965 novel of the
same name Emmy winner Carol O'Connor
Stars alongside the Emmy and
oscar-nominated Howard Rollins as a
white Southern Police Chief and black
detective respectively who set aside
racial animosity to try and solve crimes
in Mississippi throughout its long run
In the Heat of the Night was a steady
force in the ratings and was nominated
for three Emmys and five Golden Globes
and it actually won two image Awards
among other accolades you'll need about
117 hours to binge the whole series on
Pluto TV but just think of all the great
80s and 90s Nostalgia that's gonna get
kicked up in the process sign me up he's
my new chief of what what are you
talking about we haven't got any
detectives coming in as our under the
radar pick is the fall this
psychological Thriller from the BBC was
actually filmed and set in Northern
Ireland it stars Jillian Anderson as a
detective brought in from the London
Police Department to catch a serial
killer who preys on female victims while
hiding in plain sight as we learn at the
beginning the killer played by Jamie
Dornan is a husband and father living a
double life and you will be darned if
he's not also pretty dang Charming for
being a serial killer the series has
three fresh Seasons under its Bell and
has been nominated for bafta awards and
for best miniseries and best leading
actor for Dornan he's really good at it
you'll need about 17 hours to binge's
series with plenty of options to stream
from and trust me it'll be very worth
your time it's real soon to stalk these
women haven't you heard there's a
Strangler in the Pro
break into their home for our editor's
pick the Brain Trust has settled on True
Detective this Anthology series from HBO
centers around police investigations
that unearth both the personal and
professional secrets of those involved
cops criminals and otherwise the series
was created and written by Nick
pizzolato with each season operating as
a self-contained narrative and including
a revolving door of big names in the
cast stars have included Matthew
McConaughey Woody Harrelson Colin
Farrell Rachel McAdams Vince Vaughn and
mahershala Ali among others True
Detective has put out three fresh
Seasons so far with two of them
certified fresh a fourth season taking
place in Alaska has actually been
ordered with Jody Foster and Kaylee
Reese set to Star until then you can
actually binge the first three seasons
in about 23 hours on HBO Max you wonder
ever
you're a bad man
World need Fan Man
we keep the other bad man from the door
all right friends we did it five titles
that you can binge right now if Luther
is your cup of detective tea now this
list was carefully curated to help you
maximize your watch time so let us know
what you think of these or if there's
another that you think would have been a
good fit for this list and as always
don't forget to find us again for more
selections based on the shows and movies
that you love it is all right here on
the Rotten Tomatoes more like this I'll
see you next time friends
[Music]
thank you